اكد يا دكتور عبد الله ربيعه المشرفه على
عمليه فصل التوام السيامي العراقي عمر
وعلي اكد ان الفحوصات الاوليه تظهر حاله
من الاستقرار بعد نهايه مرحله التعقيب
الاولى
نحن الان اتمنى المرحله الاولى وبدايه
المرحله الثانيه وهي مرحله التعقيم التوام
الان وضعهم ولله الحمد مستقر كل المؤشرات
الحويه ولله الحمد جيده تم تركيب اجهزه
التخدير انابيب التخدير همم انابيب الخاص
الوليديه همم قساطر الرقابه الحيويه
فالوضع ولله الحمد مطمن بعد مرحله التعقيم
التي لن تاخذ طويلا سوف تبدا فتح الجراح
للتوام
والدخول في منطقه اسفل الصدر والبطن
والتاكد بشكل اكيد من الاشتراكات التي
اظهرت الفحوصات ان التوام مشتركين او
مشتركان في همم الكبد والقنوات الصفراويه
او المراريه